welcome back Center well senior Primary
Care the sponsors of this segment are
here to keep our seniors healthy and
sharp Rocky has more
Dr Wakefield welcome back
oh nice to see you see you again Rocky
great to see you too you're taking care
of our seniors at Center well and let's
talk brain health you know why are
seniors or why should seniors be aware
of changes in their brain as they age
well we can all expect some changes in
our brain as we age and we may notice
that we yeah that we that we process
things a little bit slower or we may
forget you know current events or
occurrences that happen and also we may
have a little more difficulty
multitasking but I think the important
thing to remember is that there are
things you can do to help preserve your
brain function and at least you know
reduce the risk of some of that
cognitive decline what should seniors
stop doing that that might well I would
say hurting their brain health yes
absolutely and I would say first and
foremost if you're smoking I would
really encourage you to quit because we
know that that will help improve your
brain function also reduces your risk of
other disorders associated with smoking
such as lung disease cancer and heart
disease so like I said if you are still
smoking I would definitely recommend
that you quit now
now quit smoking but also are there any
foods that people should stop eating or
are there any dietary recommendations
that help improve brain health
absolutely we know that diet does play a
part in maintaining our you know our
good brain function so it's important to
have a diet rich and lean protein but
also remember don't forget those fruits
and vegetables berries nuts and seeds
it's important also to stay well
hydrated in the day particularly in you
know hot days in Las Vegas to maintain
your you know Great Brain Health that
you can staying hydrated is not easy
here so thank you for that reminder and
what are some dietary supplements that
maybe we can add to our diets
so I would definitely recommend taking a
vitamin B12 supplement because we know
that that helps maintain brain health
and if with regards to other supplements
I think it's really important to discuss
that with your own personal physician as
they may be able to determine what other
needs you have based on the specific
conditions
um that that you know that affect you or
running your family or things like that
so important like I said B12 yes and
then anything else I would definitely
discuss with your own private position
now how does Center well help seniors
with their cognitive decline or
preventing their cognitive decline I
should say so the nice thing about
cinerals we really have that holistic
approach because we understand how a lot
of these things are interdependent on
maintaining you know brain health and we
you know address not only your physical
needs your emotional needs your social
needs as well as your financial needs
because we understand that we really
have to pay attention to all of this to
optimize your health in particular later
brain
for more information head to
centerwelllasvegas.com